for those who are forced to flee there
is often an eternal longing to return
home climate change is also a driver of
conflict in Northern Nigeria where Boko
Haram Rebels destroyed houses and drove
thousands into camps in Borno State but
now some of them are going home as DW
news Africa's amaka Okoye reports from
the region
hundreds of new homes A New Beginning
for old inhabitants
in 2015 Boko Haram insurgents drove the
people of angaranam from their Old
Village leaving them to find refuge in
camps
now years later they are going home
they'll leave behind the tents they've
sheltered in for years
and after the pain they have endured
finally there is relief
we're going back to garanam
will be able to grow food for ourselves
and our children we are tired of living
away from home
issue
I'm happy that I'm returning home and
getting a house I never ever thought I
could find someone who could build a
house for me and I can return home
I'm returning to garanam so I can live
peacefully no fears no trouble anymore
that's why I'm excited to be going back
to karanam
some years ago this community
was completely flattened out destroyed
peoples were displaced and livelihoods
destroyed but now the story has changed
as they are back into the community
being resettled and starting their lives
afresh again
Sally lost everything on the night of
the attack
since then he's lived in three different
camps
his new house is bigger and has more
rooms than his old one
he's looking forward to moving in and
enjoying the freedom that comes with
living here
our lives have returned to normal like
before
look at our rooms
you can get up at 10 in the morning and
leave the house and no one will bother
you
no one will wake you up from sleep and
ask you to go to another place
no one will give you any restrictions
like in the camps
now it is my house and I am in charge
okay
one of Nigeria's foremost Architects
tosin oshinawa crafted the buildings
known for her Creative Solutions she
says consultation with the people was
key to coming up with designs that
resonated with them you know it's very
important to me that people should be
proud of their home
I think if people have pride in where
they live and have peace of mind
anything can be achieved it means so
much to be able to sleep somewhere in
safety and in comfort and be able to get
up in the morning and go to work and be
able to raise your children to be able
to to to walk around to meet your
friends to speak with family at peace
the project is a joint effort of the
Borno State government and the United
Nations development program and its
donors
the aim is to replicate this model
elsewhere
[Music]
a decade ability to come back home
not only to come back home for a decade
they have been in camps
and you know camps are important in
terms of saving lives and providing
security but also takes away dignity for
many people so here is also coming back
to dignity but the Insurgency and
violent extremism are not banished from
Bruno State completely
there remains concerns about Security in
many areas
but for the people of hungarnam there is
at least a return to dignity as they
ReDiscover normal life again
my next guest is the architect who
designed the homes you just saw in that
report tosin oshino she joins us from
Lagos welcome to DW news Africa Chelsea
and it's good to see you so you're An
Architect by trade how was this project
different to the homes that you've
designed before
so uh thank you for having me this is
the first project that I've done within
the humanitarian sector I do tend to
work in the private sector so dealing
with individual clients or companies
corporations and this project
specifically was different
um because it's humanitarian and there
were a lot of stakeholders But
ultimately what was really important to
me was ensuring that I was still
treating the community as as a private
client so it was important to me to
ensure that I was able to speak to them
about their requirements what exactly
they needed in their homes
um
one of the questions I asked them in the
in one of the consultation meetings was
what color they would like their
buildings to be and I had already seen
some traditional buildings in the area
and the location where we had this
meeting was in a school and there was a
color that's very close to what's called
an Abuja Brown and that's actually very
similar to the color of their vernacular
um the traditional building walls and I
realized that this was really a call of
nostalgia which they didn't realize and
it was
um because of that I was very specific
that we would have to ensure that we use
the ground condition to create the
finish on the walls of the buildings so
obviously trying to as much as possible
take them back to what they would have
had before the Insurgency challenges and
it really looks stunning those those
colors are really compelling but we
heard from some of the beneficiaries in
the report and they expressed how much
it means to them to finally have decent
housing
um what has this meant for you to be
able to be involved in a project that's
about restoring the Dignity of your
fellow countrymen and women who who've
been the victims of Boko Haram
I think it's it means so much it's it's
the most impactful work I've done to
date and to to be able to contribute
towards that and it's little things you
know it's making sure that you're
providing housing that's comfortable for
the entries across ventilation making
sure that the homes are appropriate that
they're not there's no buildup of heat
um having Veranda areas for them to sit
outside because there isn't much cannot
be covered because of the vision and
also because a lot of the vegetation
have been taken down to reduce lines of
sites
um to reduce that
um conflicts of lines of sight so you
know it means so much and and to know
that one is really adding value
um to people's lives and hopefully
providing them infrastructure that will
give them the opportunity to really get
back to what they need to do to have
um at least Progressive Economic
Development yes it means a lot
incredible stuff and thank you for the
time you've taken to to be on the
program great work tosin oshino are
talking to us from Lagos there thank you